[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it's me
here Ericson alongside this guy I know
his name what is it Andrew Flash Gordon
is that your middle name flash it's just
a nickname that somebody's brother on
this channel gave me God I missed out on
all of that I thought it was his actual
middle name and it would made me like
him more listen today we're going to
watch shudder
Island we have never seen it all I know
is it's got Leo deap in it and I'm down
for that leave a like leave a comment
and also don't forget to ring the
bell ring the bell and if you haven't
joined patreon we call you super sexy
over there and you can sync up with your
own copy in wat shatter island with me
and Andrew Andrew is a book of
references I am not so he'll make a lot
of those I won't I'll just be I don't
know doing Terra stuff I guess also Greg
and John have exclusive watch alongs and
highlights over there on patreon so you
just just get over there it become super
sexy you know the deal listen are you
ready to watch us Andrew oh I'm so
excited let's do it
right I'm already liking the
music
oh aat it was so foggy yesterday
too pull yourself together titty pull
yourself
together oh God sea sickness it's just
water it's a lot of water he's like I
was already on water and Titanic I know
how this works I I don't want to be here
also like you have seasickness right
you're not just afraid of water I guess
we'll find
out hey it's the Hulk look at him Mark
Ruffalo he looks so handsome some in the
shot you're my new partner that's right
how long you been with the marshs 4
years what about you you got a girl B I
was oh he's wearing that tie
[Music]
today oh
Michelle she died a there was a fire at
the apartment building while I was at
work four people died it was a smoke the
gner not the fires that's a good
observation on the tie I didn't even
give you a briefing about the
institution before you left all I know
is it's a mental hospital well it's just
folks running around hearing voices and
chasing after butterflies they wouldn't
eat
us oh getting on to the island quickly
all right we are wasting no time the
island of the insane the other side of
the island is Rock Bluffs all the way
down to the edge of the water the dock
it's the only way on WE off love it hey
the scope of it is been also the
isolation too so Eerie it makes it feel
yeah very like spooky and ominous I'm
Deputy W mcf and gentlemen welcome to
Shadow Island I'll be the one taking you
up to
[Applause]
ashcliff this music is really setting us
up
yeah wow that's an incredible shot
yeah
you know this would be a perfect place
for a haunted house I feel like yeah
everybody's just got to shuttle on a
yeah take the boat to the to the island
Bo for three hours to get there I would
do it hell I would do it too electrified
perimeter can you tell seen something
like it before is Ward a the male Ward
Ward B the female Ward is the one on
your left Ward C the most dangerous
patients a house there admittance to w c
is forbidden without the written consent
and physical presence of both myself and
Dr Cary you're hereby required to
surrender your Firearms okay let's get
out of here yeah what why I mean they
probably have more training than the
federal penitentiary
guys oh maybe
not when did she Escape I'm afraid Dr
colie will have to fill you in on the
situation whoa she looks haunted on the
inside
yep hey Ben Kingsley I didn't know he
was in this two Marvel actors here the
Hulk and Trevor Slattery female prisoner
patient Rachel candoo last night between
10 and midnight she considered dangerous
she killed all three of her children oh
oh the most dangerous of all my one held
their heads under till they died then
she brought them back inside and
arranged them around the kitchen table
she ate a meal there before a neighbor
dropped by oh my God my God and what
about the husband he died on the beaches
at Normandy she's a war widow she stared
herself when she first came here she
insisted the children weren't dead oh oh
my God I love her Emily Mor yeah wait
was that who she he saw on the
contacts no uh no today I'm a a little
more prone to seasickness ah dehydration
in that case you're quite right the
simpler the better thanks so much Rachel
Su believes the children are alive ah to
sustain the delusion that her children
never died she's created an elaborate
fictional structure and she gives us all
parts to play in that fiction jeez I
should start trying that out in real
life that's elaborate we don't know how
she got out of her room it was locked
from the outside and the only Windows
barred I'd ask her about surveillance
but this is 54 so she's a witch How many
pairs of shoes are the patients given
two pairs she left here
Barefoot dig her way out like alcatra
[Music]
style who is 67 I think it's just random
scribblings oh Rachel smart this paper
could be important excuse me doctor this
is evidence it's a clue
last night there were seven men sitting
at the base of those stairs playing stud
poker yet somehow Rachel managed to slip
past them sounds like a conspiracy we're
going to need to speak with the staff I
feel like they killed room after dinner
if you have any further questions feel
free to join the deputy warden in the
search this location's incredible though
yeah it's 11 mil to the nearest land and
the water's freezing tent was strong
last night she had drowned have been
crushed on the rocks and a body would
have washed back up on shore loving all
these like crane shots yeah they're
awesome the cinematography is great so
far who else does she have to pass to
get down
here me oh he was in Jack Reacher and
you were at your post all night yeah but
I didn't see a thing uhhuh yeah he's
lying he's looking down when he answer
the
question tell me the truth and maybe
went to the bathroom Miss saland was
putting her room for lights out does
anyone here know what she did before
that she was in a group therapy session
anything unusual occur this is a mental
institution usual isn't a big part of
our
day good point you were there was there
a doctor present Dr Shen led the
discussion he's Rachel's primary the
psychiatrist who directly oversees her
care have we not met him yet I don't
think so we're going to need to speak
with Dr Sheen I'm afraid that won't be
possible what he left on the ferry this
morning a dangerous patient has escaped
and you let her primary doctor leave
yeah on a fairy the doctor and her are
doing the juice he took her away maybe I
wonder if she escaped on that fairy
hello anybody there all communication on
the island down down all the lines
yeah uh great plan like afraid of the
rain it's going to shut down
communication she happens to be very
smart but I'll be having drinks in a
cigar at my house around 9: we can talk
then right we have been talking
Marshall he's got some kind of sinister
Vibe about himy hiding a secret right
[Music]
yeah got to say I'm thinking I got in
the wrong line of Public Service
seriously yeah where do I sign up to be
a
psychiatrist nice music who is that
[Music]
brms it's marer forgive me gentleman my
colleague Dr Jeremiah net for piano
Max vono we saw him an exorcist yes your
profession doctor Psychiatry yes I
always heard it was overrun with boozes
and
drunks not that I've noticed is he's
drinking what's that ice tea in your
glass
there excellent Marshall you have
outstanding defense mechanisms don't you
dare analyze
me I feel like that doctor who was just
the Exorcist guy was just like brought
him in for a reason not of a stretch DOC
for all you know we're were both paper
pushers over there no you are
[Music]
not oh boy it's a lot of red and
Ledger huh ah I had a feeling that's
where we were going here yeah yeah and
who raced you me
wolves very impressive defense
[Music]
mechanisms
yeah normally I'd have sympathy but you
know he's the nword so uh not at
all Evil
Soul oh boy yes uh delete him delete him
right now please yeah as a Jew you may
delete him or just let him do it himself
right or you could just let him bleed
out maybe yeah be let him let him just
uh wall up in pain nice yeah you be in
pain sir yeah despicable being yeah uh
seen a death camp
doctor
conent English English is z good fast
perfect his English really is very good
he hit the consonant a tad hard though
oh is he ziming we're going to need
those files on Sheen and the rest of the
staff as well out of the question
out of the question who is in
charge here anyway huh yeah exactly
we're going to file our reports and
we're going to hand it over to Ho's boy
Hoover's boys that's right we taking the
fer back in the morning if they make it
there love Leo's
tempers we haven't heard the truth once
Yet chuck listen Rachel solo didn't slip
out of a locked cell Barefoot without
any help no crap yeah but the thing is
if she did get help why did they call it
in and then like right I'm curious about
that maybe it's to get the the
psychiatrist that helps her like maybe
the psychiatrist messed up too and
they're trying to like put it on her I'm
very curious how this cuz like why is
heol I found a whole stack of these
Teddy Jesus are you ever sober
anymore killed a lot of people he's got
major PTSD is that why you drink it's
not why I drink I just like it yeah you
real amen no she's still here who oh
Emily Mortimer she never
[Music]
left W that's a awesome shot yeah these
shots are incredible that's beautiful
remember when we stayed in the cabin in
the summer Teddy was so happy she's here
you can't
leave
what I'm not going to leave I love you
so
much
a you have to wake up
wow go wow this is a beautiful work of
art in regards to how they're shooting
this you have to face that but she is so
is he who lers please I need a whole
[Music]
a
wow
oh oh wow oh okay oh yeah it's going to
say how what how did that
happen oh great they're not going to be
able to get out of there now going to
say are they going to be able to leave
there's no way she was so sweet but you
could see it in her eyes she liked to be
naked to
suck
what I did not expect that she drowned
her kids this is a sick world we live in
I'll tell you that you know what they
should be gassed oh oh boy the
your the oh this Shutter Island is
getting worse and worse with every word
that nurse maybe maybe she had kids huh
a husband is trying to make ends meet a
normal
life Nails on a chalkboard for him yeah
could you stop that please please please
stop don't patient Nam manre latus do
you no no I want to go
back come on Leo's just got this
intensity he really just so good yeah
the second he he gets stopped he just
when he pulled back got it so great you
seem quite quite normal the difference
is uh most people don't kill their
husbands with an axe if a man beats you
and half the women he sees and no one
will help you
he had it coming I mean sure and Dr
Sheen was there that night yes he talked
about anger what's he like he reminds me
of my husband okay nice um did he ever
make a pass at you no Dr Shan's a good
doctor he would never could I have a
glass of water please no problem feel
like maybe this Milkman delivery man
whatever is like a oh madeup line that
they tell him to
[Music]
say
uh what oh I don't know what she wrote
did you ever meet a patient named Andre
lus never heard of her oh God like
they're all lying but why requested it
specifically you understand what Andrew
lus the maintenance man in the apartment
building where my wife and I live what
okay there's also a fire bug Andrew lus
lit the match that caused the fire
that killed my wife oh oh that changes
things about a year ago I opened up the
paper and there he is he burned down a
Schoolhouse killed two people said
voices told him to do it first he went
to prison then he got transferred here
oh pretty sure he's not in Ward B that
leaves Ward C oh it could be dead so
could Rachel cando for that matter lot
of places to hide a body here only one
place no one would really notice are
they going into W see Bridget Kar when
she sent me for water she said something
to you back there didn't she no she
didn't technically say anything yeah she
wrote it
down oh okay God this wind and this rain
I don't know how they shot it because it
looks it it's convincing yeah well
obviously we don't get this type of
weather here but right
ah oh my goodness
wow they yeah no it really does look
convincing
yeah it's like the war what is when we
got through the gates at doal the SS God
surrendered the common dant tried to
kill himself before we got there but he
botched it took him an hour to die oh
that was his own okay got it that makes
sense when I went outside I saw all the
bodies on the ground I've seen so many
history videos it's
terrible oh God the worst thing that
would give such PTSD to have witnessed
that horror on top of actually being in
War I just for survival the god
surrendered we took their guns we lined
them up
normally I'm for taking prisoners but in
this case I'm you're like bye-bye now
you all die like yeah like what kind of
effed up world are we living in that you
thought that would be okay yeah
well I
mean wow what an insane shot I mean yeah
it was amazing y'all took the lives of
millions of innocent men women and
children so starved them yeah hard hard
to have sympathy on y'all you think
that's going on here like I said no one
would talk right till I found somebody
who used to be a patient here guy's name
is George noise nice college kid
socialist sounds noise yeah he almost
beats his Professor to death ends up
here in ashcliff Ward seed oh boy so
what do you really here to do Ted I'm
going to get the proof I'm going to go
back and I'm going to blow the lid off
this place
are you able to get off this place
waiting for a chance to get out here and
then suddenly they need a US Marshal I
got lucky there was a patient Escape it
was the perfect excuse the world doesn't
work that way they got an electrified
fence around a septic facility exactly
that's what I'm they knew who you were
before getting in here right everything
about this place stinks a government Ops
what if they wanted you here
you were asking questions oh
there's no way they could have known I'd
be a to the SK there's no way well you
were looking into them they were looking
into you all they had to do is fake and
escape to get you here and now they have
you now they have us both it's a
conspiracy
W Marshall are you out here this is
Deputy w
m that's a great shot in the middle of
the ocean during a hurricane a lot of
flooding seems like a distinct
possibility it's a gamble Steven say the
power fails there's a backup generator
and if that goes the cell doors will
open oh boy 24 human beings I put all 42
inwards A and B in manual restraints as
well you said you had no idea what that
second line could refer to who was 67 24
patients and 42 patients a total of what
66 patients at this facility oh one's
missing what seems to me Rachel solando
is suggesting that you have a 67th
patient doctor didn't mcferson tell you
the good news Rachel's been found what
what so who's the 67 seventh
patient hey I love her so much know
she's so good but she's there she is
it's so antil climate like so what it's
got to be it's got to be the the the
German doctor guy there's been a
sighting of a known communist subversive
in this area passing out literature M if
you could tell us what you did yesterday
where you were I made breakfast for Jim
and the children packed Jim's lunch and
he left and I sent the children off to
school and then I decided to take a long
swim in the lake after
that uh what this is getting dark I
thought of you huh don't you know how
long have
been she mistaking him for her
husband how am I supposed to
survive car I'm so sorry but
everything's going to be all
right I buried you I buried an empty
casket your body rained down lumps of
Flesh splashing into the sea eaten by
sharks my Gym's dead so who the who are
you oh no idea how she got out but I'm
going to have to ask you to go down into
the basement there's food water and cots
are they poisoning him like why does he
keep getting these headaches so goddamn
bright is is it are you having a
[Music]
migraine what's wrong
with Marsh couple of hours you'll be as
clear as a B's he's having a migraine
imagine someone sort open your head yeah
he's spring the back of the
head sure
everything's is he being put in with the
patience is it oh cuz was there flooding
who is that him that's the war they're
they're just meeting the warden now
right what what is going on here this is
some weird
conspiracy it looks like an exmilitary
prick huh you know what I ain't going to
argue with you on that
one I mean you're right it does feel
like he's been drugged right like all
these things are happening I feel like
Mark Ruffo had a really good point and
also where's that psychiatrist that went
away on the fery that day nothing makes
sense right
[Music]
now this music with the way this is oh
yep right this music is freaking me out
yeah it's like giving me underlying
anxiety the way that it's done yeah you
don't know when that dumbbells is going
to come up you should have saved me you
should have saved all of us does he feel
some sort of I mean I know he feels I
know I would assume he feels some kind
of guilt that he couldn't save his wife
in the fire but Ian does he feel that in
the war too I feel like with his
flashbacks the way he talks about it I
feel like he hey Elias CZ Casey Jones T
mut Ninja Turtles yes sir great actor
hey buddy oh that's the the actor who or
the character of
[Music]
yeah that had some crazy makeup no hard
feelings
right no hard
feelings don't trust that man with fire
does that man even exist right now this
is what a dreamer all in his
head like it's all in his head like the
flashback wife right oh yeah running out
of the
[Music]
time whoa did you see that Holy junk how
the smoke see went back in
ah I could get into
trouble oh my God this is so hard to
look at I know it's not real but still
I'm so
sorry why didn't you see me but by the
time I got there it was too late
[Music]
that is one freaky
nightmare is his wife who the hell is
this oh his wife yeah so he woke up to
this you you need to find him and you
kill him
dead backup generators failed whole
place is going crazy oh
God Christ relax
no okay so they got released and all the
doors opened right yeah
yeah yeah I guess I'd be asking for my
weapon back electrical system is fried
feels a Jurassic parkes yeah right nice
day for a stroll don't you think
toward C for example maybe we'll run
into Andrew lus oh that's a good point
they might run into him we got most of
the bugs he's locked down now but some
of them are still loose and if you see
one don't try to restrain them
yourselves these will kill you if he
runs into that guy he's not going to try
and restrain him going to do something
else to him
yeah God the atmosphere they've created
in this movie it's great I I keep
thinking like wow why is nobody done a
Shutter Island haunted house seriously
like that would miss opportuni so far
such an experience oh yeah I can feel
him tag you're
in that's that's a fun game yeah but
probably just no it's too dark oh
God losing him in the
shadows
tag you're it oh that was good timing
you were like so in sync I was like have
you seen this how did you get that so uh
I took a wild guess I don't want to
leave here all right we hear things here
about TOS about each bomb
test you know how a hydrogen bomb Works
other bombs explode right it implodes
creating an explosion to the thousands
the the Millions the
G
oh catch them not killed them he jumped
us I mean to be fair it was technically
selfdefense guy was in a headlock for
like a good five minutes had him there
yeah he didn't like just no jump all of
a sudden on him and start beating him I
mean that guy could have killed
him
those 10
times the sound design in this is like
wow running out of mat
this
lus that's pretty damn funny is it him
let me see a goddamn face now what so
you can lie to me more this isn't about
the truth yes it is it's about Expos the
truth what about you I don't think it's
him I was
incidental a way in oh Jackie Earl haly
George no you can't be here you like it
who did this to you George you did tell
me how they got you here they know the
whole plan this is a game you're not
investigating
anything oh is he the test subject you
talking about Leo yes yeah I think is he
67 I think he might be number 67 yeah
he's a US Marshal you never worked with
him before have you cuz everything has
seemed too convenient up until this
point till he just said that she's
dead let her go tell him about the day
you brought me my locket you got to do
it I can't you have to let it go I can't
then you'll never leave this
island revenge or the truth he's not in
this W he's transfered if he's not in w
a only one place he can be wait are I
thought they were in W C they are so is
he saying White House oh okay it's an
interesting year for Jackie Earl Haley
because he's he did this and he did
Freddy Krueger nightmare in Elm Street
this year this is a far superior film
his intake for him the only thing in his
files yeah take a look I'll look at it
later it's met boys look it over later
that's all uh not trusting him anymore
yeah not after what he heard you brought
me into this boss and now we're trapped
here on this rock no one to rely on but
each other and now you're you're acting
like like what like what like you're
crazy damn it I knew it wouldn't take
long but I couldn't get to it the tide
was
up
Chuck Chuck leave the form for him
or oh no what is this he
jumped oh
no oh
okay
[Music]
what come
on what
[Music]
M
no wonder if uh BL is in or oh is that
Emily who are you I think it's Emily her
I'm a
cop it looks like Marshall Laura no no
it's not her it's a different lady I'm
going to keep
this if you don't
mind it's fine by
me Rachel
solando what the real one oh did you
kill your children what I never had
children what is going on and before I
was a patient at ashcliff I worked here
what what oh once you're declared insane
then anything you do is called part of
that Insanity reasonable protest or
denial survival instincts are you're
smarter than you look
Marshall I started asking about these
large shipments of sodium amatol and
opium based hallucinogens psychotropic
drugs ever heard of a transorbital
labotomy oh I was going to say is
labotomy he at the patient with
electroshock and go through the eye with
an ice
pick NOP m pull out some ner fibers I
don't want to see that please don't cut
to that just the description recreate a
man so he doesn't feel pain or love or
or or sympathy the Pain part I like
everything else now I don't want to be a
zombie to have that kind of ability that
kind of knowledge that that would take
years years years of research hundreds
of patients to experiment on oh they're
experimenting on these okay these are
their guinea pigs the Nazis use a jeice
Soviets use prisoners in their own guls
and we tested patients on shedar island
wow so now he's got a moral decision the
truth or his wife's killer so that when
they commit you here your friends and
colleagues oh yeah that makes sense cuz
he's been obsessed with his wife's death
they can say that about anyone anyone at
all point is are going to say it about
you yeah how's your
head oh cuz the migrant
yeah tell us they have been drugging him
I am prone to migraines yes you haven't
taken any pills I mean even aspirin the
the aspirin you ate the food in the
cafeteria and drunk the coffee they gave
you leis said you've been smoking your
own cigarettes uh it takes 36 to 48
hours for neuroleptic narcotics to reach
workable levels in the bloodstream oh no
uhoh tell me what goes on in that
Lighthouse brain surgery now let's open
the skull and see what happens if we
pull on this car
oh God who knows about this everyone
everyone wow total conspiracy I guess we
know we have that German doctor too I
had a friend I was with him yesterday
but we got separated have you seen him
you have no friends cold hard truth but
that scene definitely filled in a lot of
planks yeah that Carly thinks you're
harmless that you can be controlled but
I know different you don't know me oh
but I do oh I know you we've known each
other for centuries what if I was to
sink my teeth into your eye right now
would you be able to stop me before I
blinded you only one way to find out
give it a
try apparently there was an unidentified
man in Ward sea yesterday he subdued a
highly dangerous patient quite handily
is this noise you said his name was hea
delusional oh extremely the patient got
so wound up by one of no's stories that
he beat him up are they talking about
him we seen him Doctor Who he going act
like he's not never came right like you
don't have a partner Marshall you came
here alone oh my
goodness oh Max F going somewhere
heading out to the fer so ah I'm afraid
it's the other way if you'll wait a
moment I'll find you someone who can
take her to the dock oh oh no no no no
no ah what's this it's it's just a
sentive what you going to do kill me
provoke can you forgive me what doesn't
provoke
you wounds can't create monsters you are
wounded
Marshall stab him yeah all
right got a lot of drugs kicking in are
you in a position to
drive what are you doing baby you got to
get to the ferry if the world thinks
that Chuck is dead and he's perfect for
their
experiments I he going to burn the car I
love this thing because you gave it to
me the truth is there's one ugly
tie I actually thought it was quite cute
yeah oh
why
no
oh
[Music]
whoa
wow that was a really cool and
interesting shot
yeah how do you get to that Lighthouse
yeah right you just got to swim there I
guess
so it's not like it's super super far oh
it's probably
freezing like we said earlier in the
film he's used to cold Waters
yeah
wow such a looming shot
[Music]
there all
right
God is there not going to be anything in
here maybe it's hidden it's just not in
plain
sight oh it's really hitting him hard
cuz you said what 36 to 48 hours right
yeah the rifle's empty by the way oh my
goodness so he's the patient he is the
experiment yes he's here have Dr Shen
take a look at your man before you send
him up oh Dr Sheen get out of here Teddy
this place is going to be the end of
you huh what the is this claw premine
the same thing we've been giving you for
the past 24 months
what you've been here what for 2 years a
patient of this institution so how was
he on that boat that was in his mind I
guess ended the mark SL you were a US
Marshall you broke into toward C4 proof
of the 67th patient notice anything
these four names have in common oh
Edward Daniels has exactly the same 13
letters as Andrew lus the same as Rachel
solando and Dolores chanal uh your name
is Andrew lus the 67th patient at
ashcliff he's you Andrew we got that
part right your crime is terrible one
you can't forgive yourself for so you
invented another self uh oh did he do
his own wife oh did they have kids cuz
the little girl yeah he I think he did
he he his kids but you're violent
trained dangerous you're the most
dangerous patient we have have a
transcript of the conversation you had
with no yesterday this is about you and
ladies if he's as violent as he's
claiming why is he allowed to be in the
room with him with right you did this no
no he meant that it was my fault you
almost killed him we can bring you back
to sanity now permanent measures will be
taken to ensure you can't hurt anyone
ever again oh my God but what about my
partner you're going to tell the US
Marshall's office that he's a defense
mechanism ah what who are you tell me
don't you recognize me Andrew I've been
your primary psychiatrist for the last 2
years what I'm Lester Sheen
oh all right that is incredible okay
what a twist
if we fail with you then everything that
we've tried to do here will be
discredited everything that's the
important
thing oh God this one's loaded I can
tell by the way my initials are on the
side there's a dent in the barrel from
when Philip stack shot him and Blast
away the only way you're ever getting
off this island
who what Andrew please don't oh what
what
what didn't we just see blood splatter
what yeah what is it's fake what
oh lying and
cigarett all you done is lying your
children Andrew your children oh so they
were his children yep you never had any
children your wife drowned them oh it
was his wife wasn't him we got him just
outside Oklahoma must have stopped 10
places in between here and Tulsa I could
sleep for a week
theoris oh
no
Dolores makes sense now why she's always
wet in his
yeah where are the
kids they're in school is it summertime
yeah it's it's like sick it's Saturday
honey school's not in on Saturday my
school is oh my God that n was a crazy
delivery
D
yeah no please
cut please
cut
wow
let's put them at the table
Andrew we'll dry them off we'll change
their clothes tomorrow we can take them
on a
picnic Set Me Free I love you too I love
you so much I love you right what
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
Andrew oh
Rachel ohel wow wow Rachel these are
crazy twists going on here why are you
here cuz I killed my wife why did you do
that because she murdered our children
who's Teddy Daniels he doesn't exist now
that is Rachel solando I made them
up why did you make them up cuz I can't
take knowing that Dolores killed our
children I killed them cuz I didn't I
didn't get her help you know I need to
know you've accepted
reality my name is Andrew lus and I
murdered my wife in the spring of
52 wow so what's our next move you you
tell me got to get off this rock chuck
get back to the mainland whatever the
hell's going on here it's
bad labotomy on him don't worry about
him they're not going to catch us that's
right we're too smart for him yeah we
are aren't we feel like he's saying that
on uh DiCaprio is saying that on purpose
to him yeah I'm like is he actually
regressing or is it a fake regression I
feel like it's a fake regression you
know this place makes me wonder he Sarah
Conor bring it out of there which would
be worse to live as a monster or to die
as a good man either die a hero or live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain H I knew I was like are we not
going to know they're going to just
black out
right I knew it oh my God ah how do you
do
that wow this is definitely one of those
films where I mean cuz you're processing
so much information the first time you
watch it I don't think I said one word
towards the end I just I was I was just
like yeah ditto yeah uh yeah because not
a lot keeps you and I usually mute um so
um but yeah no this is one of those I
mean I I love a good
mystery film um and I love the
psychological aspects of this film uh
very much so but this is definitely one
of those films where you got to watch it
a second third or even fourth time to
pick up different layers of things that
were again because there's so much stuff
being thrown at you from the first time
you're like like like I said there were
times where um it's like okay blanks are
being filled in now um so but I mean the
twists and the turns I know we were able
to process uh that okay we're assuming
Leo is 67th patient but it was more late
into it after he was talking to noise
yeah yeah that was once he got to
jackier Haley's character of noise but I
mean even even once we deduced that
there was still so much more of the I
mean cuz yeah like when we were watching
that he was uh seeing the visions of his
wife I mean I figur that was all from
either PTSD you know from Miss
and also PTSD just from missing her as
well on top of the war stuff but also
when he was getting the visions of
seeing the the children I'm like why is
he getting visions of what was Emily
mortimer's charact that was before the
reveal of Holocaust yeah but well yeah I
mean or as a Vic well I figured that
those were Emily mortimer's children you
remember cuz they said those were her
three children I like why do we keep
getting cuz I mean I'm sure he feels
terrible about what happened but why do
we keep getting it was just such a smart
way I just I love the uh just so many
different plot it just this movie just
messed with my yeah fittingly so messed
with my mind um but what do you think of
this film oh God I mean it was great I
do agree that the setups of him flashing
back to like his War days and we we you
said you like does he feel a sense of
responsibility uh in regards to like the
war even though he was just there and
it's like putting now putting Emily's
like uh in there with the girl brought
it all back to like he does cuz he
killed his wife right
yeah uh yeah there's so much normally I
feel like in a movie I number one I love
the soundtrack it's such it's so huge
and so epic and every time they would
they would get to the location then it
would just like stop which I I really I
really enjoyed the cinematography
especially the crane shots were amazing
and the sound design gave me so much
anxiety every time I was lighting a
match it just was like you felt like you
were right there lighting it and it was
going to burn your fingers um all of
those it it kept me on edge and I feel
like mainly most movies I can or we
could see what's coming yeah and I did
not I didn't I did not and everyone in
here is just so brilliant oh yeah and
grounded and just I never normally when
I'm sure when we watch movies there's
always like a character or two that you
can kind of feel like I feel like
they're acting and in this I was like I
was never like as an actor right I tend
to notice those things more and in this
I it was never taken out by anybody it
just was
so they were so in character like
literally um so much no and I agree with
you like just from all the sound design
and the and the score I'll have to look
up when we're done but the score um was
just I was just I just felt like and
also too just again from the setting too
I just I felt anxiety and and a a sense
of claustrophobic yes uh you know just
from just everything happening but and
even too once we had deduced that he was
the 67th uh patient it didn't M because
there was so much else going on you know
from the what we had learned with his
wife and then uh that it was their
children and that all these names were
just what anagrams or whatever um so I
mean there was again I just loved all
the twist uh I loved what you mentioned
too about the cinematography it was the
crane shots it was it was just so
beautifully done then there was some uh
really nice zoom in shots as well uh I
also noticed too it said uh when we were
watching the credits here that it said
that they had a psychiatric consultant
you can tell there was a lot of care
that went into this because again like
after just watching this and fresh
talking about it like I'm just this is
such a this film was just such a mind
trip yeah um just really got to me in
that way because like I said we we don't
usually not say anything when we're
watching a movie right but I didn't have
I was just like uh yeah it's one of
those types of films you in it yeah for
sure um but DiCaprio I mean that guy
just he never ceases to amaz his
performance was incredible and I mean
it's quite I love seeing the progression
of change too once we get the reveals
his not only yeah all that too and like
his hair just how everything just starts
coming unglued like cuz when he first
comes on to the island yeah we see that
he gets seasick and all that I mean
that's just a normal thing for a lot of
people but you can just see uh that
sense of like Authority and confidence
when he comes on like he's going to
catch uh the Rachel whoever's missing uh
and just like the sense of entitlement
of hey I'm here to do a job I'm going to
do it and get off the island and then
like like just getting crazier and
losing like a sense of mobility and all
that just in general and I just I
thought he just did such a great job of
just like feeling that like just I felt
so bad for his character just like
progressing throughout the film watching
him lose his mind s to speak literally
um but just what a phenomenal
performance um but yeah and this film
just did such a great job of again just
repeating myself even though we figured
out he was the 6 I had no idea what else
was going on I mean there were so many
times like what's What's Happening Here
what's happening here what's going on
here and then when it was really I
didn't see that coming so I'm always
happy when films can Shock Me Not only
just shock me but Shock Me In A
satisfying way to where it's you know it
it Services the storyline and the
characters uh and I thought this film
just did that in phenomenal ways this is
really intriguing film and I can't wait
to see it again
because there were so many like this is
again one of those films where you got
to watch it a second third time where
you're like okay that way you can sort
of pick out yeah cuz now you know the
twist you know what's coming now it's
like okay now I can pick up on certain
things that um and I did mention earlier
too I know you're going to have no idea
what I'm talking about I would
assume because I know the show ended in
2011 on season 10 this is where my crazy
memory comes up but I'm talking about
Smallville there was an episode of small
Ville that they did I believe it was
season 6 where Clark Kent I think you
know who that is Tom Wellings Clark Kent
he was in a psych ward uh he was being
it was a phantom uh from um uh the uh
from um uh where Jerel keeps them um and
anyways uh he was in like a psych where
it was a very similar uh storyline to
this so I just my mind kept on going
back to this it didn't quite end as
similarly as this but um yeah the way
this ended though I was like
oh jeez it's so ambiguous but you know
it is but also too if you remember do
you remember the opening shot opened
even though it was foggy it opened on a
white light mhm so I it was very you
know when I watched that the second time
I was almost like is this kind of a
dreames like you know what I mean
opening kind thing cuz is this setting
us up so that at the end we know like
was this all a dream yeah well just or
in his head right type of thing so um
yeah no there was just a very very
interesting film like I said mind trip
DiCaprio was phenomenal King I mean all
the actors were so good Allstar cast too
amazing amazing I mean when you got cing
DiCaprio I'm sure everyone's everyone's
going to be like please let me be in it
seriously all the allstar are going to
want to join but um the the setups the
writing the cinematography the music the
sound design the acting um the twists
there's just so many different things I
could praise about this movie and I know
especially like towards the end though
too with Michelle when they they
actually displayed the the killing of
how she did it and how it was revealed
of her coming up to him and and her
saying mine's not like her it's not a
school day or whatever whatever that
line is she's saying it's it's a school
day for her and then you cut to the kids
you're setting it up really for him as
like a human being realizing that is the
moment that has led him so far cuz
before seeing all this and us going
maybe he's a 67th patient kept us
guessing why he would be that person un
even hearing like the the the stories or
whatnot it wasn't until like you're
really placed with them there at the end
seeing how it was revealed that he that
was his wife made it um gave him a
little more like of the humanity so when
you when you hear him confess to saying
I killed my wife because she murdered my
three children and then we see him sort
of acting like yeah we got to I got to
get off this rock man they they I got to
get out of here whatever's happening is
not good you're like H yeah is he
regressing or is he faking and I'm like
wouldn't be surprised if he's regressing
because a lot of what he just said is so
much and they gave us a picture into
that right yeah um do you remember what
the I'm sorry but do you remember what
that note I know the note had the 67 but
it had something about the number four
right the only reason I mentioned that
is because it was his his three children
and his wife right so that's the four
and then he's the 67 so I assume that's
the par okay and also too they did show
us at the beginning or when he was in
the um I believe it's the first night he
was staying there if you remember she
was dripping wet in his in that uh in
the dream or whatever and then he was
Dripping we're like wait how did that
happen then we saw that the water was
coming but I think they were just they
were setting us up because from all she
obviously she had drown the children and
then he had gone into the water so yeah
I mean there was just so like again
that's the when you watch the movie
again you're going to notice these
things that's why it's like he's saying
I just don't do well with water in the
beginning it adds it all you're
like you're literally screwed from like
water in general makes bad I didn't even
think about that makes total I was
making that Titanic joke at the
beginning which still makes sense but um
no that makes I didn't even think about
that but had you not said that when I'd
watched now the second time like okay
now I'm understanding now why if he's
anywhere near water he's he's going to
like feel vomity or not or feel sick not
well yeah not well because there would
be major PTSD anywhere near any kind of
water so of water so yeah that makes
total sense the ending too with the
nurse coming out you see it in the
napkin it looks like the long like
needle that they're going
to yeah uh right there in the old eye
I'm just glad they didn't show that I'm
glad they didn't do that either um and
you just kind of go yeah cutting to the
lighthouse we see the Fate that awaits
us uh I guess but it's funny cuz they're
saying
when they when they were in the
lighthouse before it was all revealed
saying you're kind of our last chance to
prove that what we're doing here is good
right that what they're doing is is a
good thing um and then the thing at the
end I'm like but does that mean they're
gonna lobotomize him because they're
trying to fight against doing that right
well that was the last that was the
their last ditch effort right have have
you seen just curious cuz I don't want
to spoil for you but have you seen Total
Recall with Arnold or no I think so but
it's been a long time and I might not
have cuz the ending uh just with how
ambiguous it was without going to
spoilers in case you ever do react to it
cuz it's been a while the the ending
with how ambiguous and talking about
labotz just very similar I'm not again
I'm not accusing them of coping anyway
just it just reminded me how similar it
was to the ending of Total Recall with
Arnold just how ambiguous and talking
about lobotomization and all that so uh
interesting but yeah yeah but uh again
just that was an interesting point you
threw out as well in terms of at the
very be I I didn't even think about that
uh when he was uh on the ship and he was
uh getting sick there just with the
water so again they're just setting us
up but I think also scres did that as
well not only to set us up but hey we
know you're going to watch this a second
third or fourth time now when you watch
this this is why he's getting sick here
yeah absolutely I mean
I eight and a half out of 10 maybe even
nine I don't know it's it's a great film
everybody in this is so freaking good
the score is great yeah the the
direction the shots everything just
draws you in I'm like it's just like a
it's a 10 out of 10 type of a film I
mean I I don't know really anything
wrong with it except I got mad I wanted
even though it's such a long movie at
the end I still was like ah I felt it
coming where you just see the lighthouse
and they're going to cut out of it but I
wanted I wanted a little a little more
of it but I yeah great fil i' probably
go e between an 8.8 and a nine somewhere
somewhere in that in that range I mean
it was it was a real good character
study um psychological mystery uh film
uh just so many different things Andi
once again just man never sees us doam
ma uh just directed the hell of this him
and uh DiCaprio such a good team those
guys they can do no wrong together uh
but I really enjoyed this film I'm
looking forward to watching it again
just picking up on things I didn't catch
the first time just again I assume like
many of you just there's so much
information to pick up the first time
just like anything you watch but
especially with a film like this and
also too I wasn't expecting it to be so
heavy-handed I didn't not going to lie I
didn't know too much about this movie I
just knew it took place on an island
which is not too much a stretch cuz it's
called shedar Island and there was some
psychological aspects but I wasn't I had
no idea there was a wife and there was
all this and I just didn't know it was
going to be so heavy-handed um so uh but
they handled it in you know such a a a
satisfying way and and such a mature way
um and it was just a really well done
film and again sces and DiCaprio another
winner for them uh fantastic job so yeah
I would say 8.8 to n somewhere somewhere
in that range
yeah and also if anybody wants to put
together edit together like a montage of
those beautiful flashback shots every
one of those shots was pure art
beautiful oh yeah and the dream
sequences doing the Flash oh God yeah
thank you so much chef's kiss yeah right
unbelievable I think that's it you got
any last words I mean we we like this
this is a beautiful piece of film art is
that my phone I think it was if it kept
going off I'm sorry hope you guys didn't
hear it uh uh no just uh again fantastic
job by Ces DiCaprio all the other actors
that they got uh score cinematography
sound design everything pristine thumbs
up fantastic art in this film so great
film glad I got to react to it with you
and to all you uh citizens of the reject
Nation thank you for joining us much
appreciated thank you so much we'll see
you next time
bye